So let's finally get to our earthquake problem. We're going to look at 2
earthquakes. One of them happened in Japan in 2011. This earthquake had a
magnitude of 9.0. The other earthquake we're going to talk about happened in
California. It was in 1857 and it had a magnitude of 7.9. This is the largest
known earthquake in California. Now what do these numbers actually mean? Well,
let's talk about the equation for the magnitude of an earthquake. let's say that
R is the magnitude of an earthquake on a Richter scale. Then for R we have the
equation R equals log base 10 of I over S. Here, I is the intensity of the
earthquake and S is equal to some constant. It's supposed to be the intensity
of some sort of standard earthquake, which just has a fixed value. We don't
need to know this value though, since we'll be eliminating it from our
equations eventually. So here, once again, is our information about our two
earthquakes. How does this information fall into an equation of this sort?
Well, we know that R is the magnitude. So that means that over here for Japan
we'll have 9.0 equals log base 10 of J over S. I'm just going to use the letter
J instead of I, to show that this in the intensity of the Japanese earthquake.
For California, we'll have something very similar. We're just going to instead
have and R value of 7.9 and I'll use the letter C to represent the intensity of
this quake, C for California. Now notice that in both of these log equations,
we have a fraction as the input to the log. What we're going to want to do
first is to split each of these up into two separate logs, since otherwise
you're not going to be able to get rid of the S. So, which property do we need
to use in order to do that? Should we use the product property, the quotient
property, the power property or the change of base property.